This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Sometimes it can feel like the past is all we have, that memory is all that we are. It's why we always return to what we did yesterday, rehashing, revisiting, that grandparents we should have visited, that summer that lasted forever. Our personal reconstructions of the past, edited, polished, and misremembered are how we make meaning of ourselves in the present. Today, two emotions that take us back in time, regret and nostalgia. The things we wish we could return to, it's like, where did all this time go? How do I already have a daughter that's kind of written from high school? And the things we wish we could change. My biggest regret is not listening to my father
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。有时，我们可能会觉得过去就是我们拥有的全部，记忆就是我们的全部。这就是为什么我们总是回到昨天做过的事情，不断咀嚼、重温，本该去拜访的祖父母，那个仿佛无边无际的夏天。我们对过去的个人重构，经过编辑、润色和错误的记忆，构成了我们在当下赋予自身意义的方式。今天，我们要探讨两种带我们回到过去的负面情绪：遗憾与怀旧。那些我们希望能够回去的事情，就像是，时间都去哪儿了？为什么我的女儿都已经从高中毕业了？以及那些我们希望能够改变的事情。我最大的遗憾是没有听父亲
tell me about the mundane things that happened to him during the day. How can we make these feelings work for us and what can we learn from them? Looking to our past to understand our present, this week on Hidden Brain. Whether or not you believe in them, you probably have ghosts that haunt you. Not something sinister, but something you just can't get rid of.
听他讲自己白天发生的那些琐事。我们如何才能让这些感受为我们所用，又能从中学到什么？本周的《隐藏的大脑》将带你回顾过去，理解当下。不管你信不信，你可能都有一些挥之不去的阴影。不是什么邪恶的东西，而是一些你就是摆脱不掉的事情。
Hi there, Sean Carr and friends. Hello, Sean Carr. Hi. Hi. I was calling about, hopefully I sang it, regrets I've had a few, so I won't list all of them. My boyfriend of a year and I end our relationship. It's just looking back and thinking that I could have done better, and I didn't. All these things keep popping in my head of small things, maybe something I should have said differently
大家好，肖恩·卡尔和朋友们。你好，肖恩·卡尔。嗨。嗨。我打电话来是想——希望我没唱错——“我有过一些遗憾”，所以我不会一一列举。我和交往了一年的男友结束了恋爱关系。回想起来，总觉得我本可以做得更好，但我没有。所有这些小事不断地在我脑海中浮现，也许有些话我本应该换个方式说
or something I should have done differently in a particular conversation or on a particular event. It makes me cringe with regret and shame. I haven't a fair. Everyone knows that it's not a secret, but it's a regret. My great regret is leaving Woodstock on Saturday morning. I was an evangelical Christian at the time, and I remember my friends asking me if I thought they were going to hell.
或者在某次特定的对话中，抑或是某个特定的活动中，我本应该做出不同的举动。这让我感到尴尬、遗憾和羞耻。我曾有过一段婚外情。大家都知道，这不是秘密，但这是一个遗憾。我最大的遗憾是周六早上离开伍德斯托克。我当时是一名福音派基督徒，我记得朋友们问我，是否认为他们会下地狱。
And I told them that I thought they would go to hell if they did not become Christian. And it's something that's bothered me for the last 10 years. I am experiencing regrets on sometimes admitted by minute basis. And it is the biggest regret of my life, honestly. Okay, I hope you have a great rest of your day. Bye. I don't know that I have a particular deep backstory about how I got into regret.
我告诉他们，如果不成为基督徒，他们就会下地狱。这件事在过去十年里一直困扰着我。我经常会产生遗憾，有时甚至是以分钟为单位。老实说，这是我一生中最大的遗憾。好了，希望你们剩下的一天过得愉快。再见。我不知道我对如何陷入遗憾有没有什么深刻的背景故事。
I actually was just generally interested in social psychology. Amy Somerville is a psychology professor at Miami University of Ohio. She runs the regret lab where she studies how people think about the choices they made and the choices they wish they'd made. One of the things that then drew me to regret from that is the fact that regret is among our most common emotions. By some estimates, it's the second most common emotion mentioned in daily life and the most common negative emotion that we mention.
其实我只是对社会心理学普遍感兴趣。艾米·萨默维尔是迈阿密大学俄亥俄分校的心理学教授。她主持“遗憾实验室”，研究人们如何看待自己做出的选择以及他们希望自己曾做出的选择。由此吸引我关注遗憾的一个原因是，遗憾是我们最普遍的情绪之一。据估计，它是日常生活中人们提到的第二常见情绪，也是我们提到的最常见的消极情绪。
And so this is really a pervasive part of how people experience the world around them. And as I learned more, I really started to realize that regret is actually a very hopeful emotion. It's something that is helping us learn from our mistakes and do better in the future. So it's actually, I think, a really positive thing to get to study. That's so interesting, Amy, because, of course course most of us think of regret as being a negative emotion because it's painful, but what you're saying makes me think about a listener who recently shared his story of regret with us.
因此，这确实是人们体验周围世界的一个无处不在的部分。随着我了解的深入，我真的开始意识到，遗憾其实是一种充满希望的情绪。它能够帮助我们从错误中吸取教训，在未来做得更好。所以，我认为研究它其实是一件非常积极的事情。这太有趣了，艾米，因为当然，我们大多数人都认为遗憾是一种消极情绪，因为它是痛苦的，但你所说的话让我想起了一位听众，他最近跟我们分享了他的遗憾故事。
His name is Tom Bonsain. Here's what he said. I regret not taking the lead in a school play when I was in ninth grade. I was in a nine through twelve school and I was surprised to receive a lead as a freshman. It was somewhat of a big deal considering that freshmen typically don't get those sort of roles. And rather than accept the fact that the director felt like I would be a good choice to the role, I listened to people who said that I probably can handle it and therefore decided to turn the role down. Later on in life, I realized that when people
他的名字叫汤姆·邦塞恩。他是这样说的。我遗憾的是在九年级时没有在学校话剧里争取主角。我当时在一所九年级到十二年级的学校上学，作为一名新生，我居然得到了一个主角，这让我感到很意外。考虑到新生通常不会得到那种角色，这算是一件大事。但我没有接受导演认为我是该角色的绝佳人选这一事实，而是听信了那些说我可能无法胜任的人的话，因此决定放弃这个角色。后来在生活中，我意识到当人们
present me with an opportunity like that, if they have the confidence in me being able to be successful, they're likely not putting in that place to fail. And so since then, I feel like I've gotten a new confidence. And so when faced with similar situations in the current dice, I've been much more likely to put my hand up and say yes. I'm wondering how common this is.
把这样的一机会摆在我面前时，如果他们对我有信心能够成功，他们大概不会把我放在一个注定会失败的位置上。所以从那以后，我觉得自己获得了新的自信。因此，在当前遇到类似情况时，我更有可能举手说“我愿意”。我很想知道这有多普遍。
Are people really good at taking what happened in the past and learning from it? What spells the difference between people who actually are behaving like Tom, taking a bad experience and saying, I'm actually going to use it, and people who just sort of stay stuck in what that bad experience was and think about it over and over again? So I think the thing that really characterizes it is less about necessarily what kind of person you are, but rather the way that you're experiencing these thoughts. So there's something called rumination, which actually comes literally from bovine digestion, the idea of how cows vomit back up things, chew them over, swallow them back down, and so on and so forth.
人们真的擅长吸取过去的经历并从中吸取教训吗？那些真正像汤姆那样，经历了一次糟糕的经历却说“我要把这个利用起来”的人，与那些只是停留在糟糕的经历中并一遍又一遍地思考它的人，区别在哪里呢？所以我认为，真正区别两者的关键，与其说是你是什么样的人，不如说是你体验这些想法的方式。有一种叫做“反刍”的现象，这个词实际上字面源自牛的消化过程，也就是牛把吃进去的东西吐出来咀嚼，然后再咽下去，以此类推。
And in terms of our thoughts, it's actually this idea of the same kind of process that rumination is having thoughts sort of spring unwanted to mind, and we're chewing them over without actually getting anything new out of them. They're just repeatedly, intrusively becoming sort of part of our mental landscape. And what we found is that people who have roominative regrets, so that they're both having this regret, but also having it be something that's intrusive and repeated, tend to be people who are also experiencing the most negative outcomes.
就我们的思维而言，反刍其实就是指这样一种过程：各种想法不受控制地涌上心头，我们在脑海中反复咀嚼它们，却没有从中获得任何新的东西。它们只是不断地、侵入式地成为我们精神世界的一部分。我们发现，那些有反刍性遗憾的人——也就是说他们既有这种遗憾，同时这种遗憾又具有侵入性和重复性——往往也是经历最多负面结果的人。
So are more likely to have clinical depression symptoms, anxiety symptoms, things like that. There are some regrets you can learn from, like Tom's story about trying out for the school play. But other regrets feel harder to overcome. I asked Amy some of her about this, and I played her the story from Catherine Wiginton Green, a listener from Washington DC.
因此，他们更有可能出现临床抑郁症状、焦虑症状诸如此类的情况。有些遗憾是你可以从中吸取教训的，比如汤姆关于试镜学校话剧的故事。但有些遗憾感觉更难以克服。我问过艾米关于这方面的问题，并给她播放了来自华盛顿特区的听众凯瑟琳·威金顿·格林的故事。
My main regret, what popped into my mind when I heard this on the podcast, was regretting not stopping and seeing my estranged father. He'd been estranged for our family for quite a while, and I had not seen him or spoken with him in a very long time, his choice. And I was driving along Barcreek Parkway, who is my boyfriend at the time, who is now my husband. And as we were driving up R.C. Parkway, I looked to my right and saw him and the woman he married, walking arm and arm. And I saw him and I told my husband to pull over, immediately without thinking. And when we stopped the car, I started to unbuckle my feet belt.
我的主要遗憾——当我在播客中听到这个时脑海中浮现的想法——是后悔没有停下来去看望我疏远的父亲。他疏远我们家已经有一段时间了，我已经很久没有见过他或跟他说话了，这是他的选择。当时我正和当时的男友、也就是现在的丈夫开车行驶在巴尔克里克公园大道上。当我们开车上公园大道时，我向右看去，看到他和他的妻子手挽着手走着。我看到他之后，立刻不假思索地告诉丈夫把车停下来。当我们把车停下时，我开始解开安全带。
And then I stopped and paused for a moment and realized, I had no idea what I was going to do or what I was going to say. So I chickened out and buckled my feet belt back and told my husband to keep driving. And then I burst into tears. And I realized that that was probably the last time I was going to see him and
然后我停顿了一会儿，意识到我根本不知道自己要做什么或说什么。于是我退缩了，重新系好安全带，告诉丈夫继续开车。接着我放声大哭。我意识到那可能是我最后一次见到他了，
that was my only chance to talk to him again. So I've still regret that. There's something really point in about that story, Amy, because in this case, it doesn't sound as if the regret has the potential for learning. She says that she feels that the door was closed in terms of her ability to reconnect with her father, and she comes back to this memory over and over again and just remembers it as an opportunity that was lost.
也是我与他再次交谈的唯一机会。所以我至今仍为此感到遗憾。那个故事里有一些非常触动人心的东西，艾米，因为在这种情况下，听起来这个遗憾似乎并没有带来学习的可能。她说她觉得在与父亲重新建立联系的能力方面，这扇门已经关上了，她一次又一次地回到这段记忆中，只是把它当作一个失去的机会。
Yeah, certainly in terms of the specific incidents that we regret, they do seem to be most likely things where we had this opportunity in the moment, but it's not something that we can go back and fix. Because obviously, if we could just magically turn back and fix something, then most people would do that rather than continue to regret it. What I might say is that I would imagine that one of the reasons that this does wrinkle for this woman is that it's about something that's important to her.
是的，确实，就我们所遗憾的具体事件而言，它们最有可能发生在我们当时有这个机会，但却无法回头去修复的事情上。因为很显然，如果我们能像变魔术一样倒转时间去修复某事，那么大多数人都会选择那样做，而不是继续遗憾下去。我想说的是，这位女士之所以对这件事耿耿于怀，原因之一可能是这事对她很重要。
It's about her family. And that perhaps this is something that she can carry forward in terms of how she handles other relationships going forward. So I've heard people say that there are anecdotal reports that the things that people really regret are the things that they didn't do rather than the things that they did do. Is that just anecdotal? Is that not actually true? that people regret acts of omission more than acts of commission? I would say there's some evidence for that. So one of the more famous studies on this thought about this in terms of something that happens over time. And what those researchers argued is that we regret things we did a lot more in the moment. So if you say something really stupid in a job interview, you're going to walk out and have that hand to the forehead feeling of, oh, why did I say that? That was such a terrible thing to
这关乎她的家庭。也许她可以把这件事带到未来的生活中，作为处理其他关系的参考。所以我曾听人说，有传闻报告称，人们真正遗憾的往往是他们没有做过的事，而不是他们做过的事。这只是传闻吗？这其实不是真的吗？人们对不作为的遗憾多于对作为的遗憾？我想说，确实有一些证据支持这一点。关于这一点，一项比较著名的研究是从时间推移的角度来思考的。这些研究人员认为，在当时，我们对自己做过的事会感到更多的遗憾。因此，如果你在求职面试中说了一些非常愚蠢的话，你走出去时就会做出拍额头的动作，心想：“天哪，我为什么会说那种话？在那个时刻说出那种话实在太糟糕了。”
have said in that moment. But in the long run, we tend to have things that are kind of incomplete goals stick around in our memory as kind of a mental to-do list, basically. And that as a result, our inactions wind up getting kind of added to that mental to-do list. So this may be something where, if you ask me, you know, what could you have done instead of going to grad school? I have this whole range of possibilities. I could have been a doctor, I could have been a writer, I could have backpacked around Europe and found my passion. And if you ask me, what are the things that you did yesterday that you could undo? Right, I have a finite set of things I actually did in my life. And so over time, it may be that when we're trying to undo something bad that's happened to us, it's easy to start imagining
但在长远来看，我们往往会将一些未完成的目标留在记忆中，基本上就像是一个精神上的待办事项清单。其结果是，我们的不作为最终会被加入到那个精神待办事项清单中。所以这可能是这样一种情况：如果你问我，你知道的，除了去读研究生，你本可以做什么？我有一整套的可能性。我本可以成为一名医生，我本可以成为一名作家，我本可以背包穷游欧洲并找到我的挚爱。而如果你问我，你昨天做过的事情里有哪些是你可以撤销的？好吧，我在生活中实际做过的事情是有限的。因此，随着时间的推移，当我们试图撤销发生在我们身上的坏事时，我们很容易开始想象
all of the things we might have done in the past because we have a lot more of those available to us than the things we actually did. There are times when we don't take responsibility for our actions, but at other times we hold ourselves accountable for things that are outside our control. James Cooper of Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania shared one of those stories with us. My biggest regret is not listening to my father tell me about the mundane things that happened to him during the day and instead just immediately asking for my mom when I called the house and maybe when I talked to him I could have picked up one of some other signs too and could have maybe prevented his suicide. You know when I heard James's story Amy I wondered whether you
我们在过去可能做过的所有事情，因为与我们实际做过的事情相比，我们能想到的可能性要多得多。有时候我们不为自己的行为承担责任，但在另一些时候，我们却把超乎我们控制的事情归咎于自己。来自宾夕法尼亚州匹兹堡的詹姆斯·库珀跟我们分享了这样一个故事。我最大的遗憾是没有听父亲跟我讲他白天发生的琐事，而是每次打电话回家时都直接找我妈妈，也许当时如果我和他多聊聊，我也能捕捉到一些其他的迹象，或许就能阻止他的自杀。你知道，当我听到詹姆斯的经历时，艾米，我想知道，
know if he had spoken to his father more, would he have actually picked up on his father's mental health? And even if he had noticed, could he have actually stopped his father from committing suicide? And it seemed to me that in this case, James might have been taking on more responsibility than was actually warranted. I mean, it's understandable, certainly, at an emotional level. But you've done some research looking at how sometimes when it comes to regret, we take on more responsibility than we should. Yeah, I think I would say exactly that.
如果他和父亲多聊聊，他真的能察觉到父亲的心理健康状况吗？即使他注意到了，他真的能阻止父亲自杀吗？在我看来，詹姆斯在这种情况下可能承担了超出实际所需的责任。我的意思是，从情感层面上讲，这当然是可以理解的。但你做过一些研究，探讨有时在面对遗憾时，我们会承担比应有的更多的责任。是的，我想我会这么说。
I think that this is a case of probably imagining that there's more that could have happened differently. And it's certainly the case as well that I think people often tend to focus a lot on their own actions about negative events. And it's probably important to think about the fact that you're just one agent in a much bigger framework that his father had other friends, hopefully had doctors, had his mother, and that it's not just on James to have recognized these symptoms, but that there were lots of other pieces that could have played out differently, not just his own actions, but a broader set of things that could have changed.
我认为这是一个典型的例子，人们倾向于想象本可以有更多不同的发展。而且，我认为人们也常常倾向于将负面事件过多地归咎于自己的行动。同样重要的一点是，你必须意识到，在一个更大的框架中，你只是其中的一个行动者。他的父亲还有其他朋友，希望还有医生，还有他的母亲，不仅仅是詹姆斯一个人应该认出这些症状，还有很多其他的因素本来可以有不同的发展，不仅是他自己的行为，还包括一套更广泛的、可能发生改变的因素。
Is there a way for people to look at their regrets and say, this is the kind of regret that is actually useful and productive, and this is the kind of regret that is actually better set aside? So yeah, I would say that we know that people tend to generate these what-if thoughts as a way of trying to understand their experiences and as a way of trying to bring control to things that feel uncontrollable. We don't like the idea that bad things happen with no reason and without the ability to predict them.
人们有没有办法审视自己的遗憾，然后说：“这种遗憾是有用且富有成效的，而那种遗憾最好还是抛开？”所以，是的，我想说，我们知道人们往往会产生这些“如果……会怎样”的想法，以此来试图理解自己的经历，并试图对那些感觉无法控制的事情施加控制。我们不喜欢糟糕的事情无缘无故地发生、且无法预测的想法。
And in the case of regret, I think it can be that in James's case, for instance, not wanting to think about this tremendous loss as something that wasn't predictable and wasn't controllable, that it's, I think, very reassuring sometimes to try to come up with an explanation of, there's a way that this could have been prevented, it could have been changed, and it feels less random and less senseless in that way. You know, I'm fascinated by what you just said because essentially what you're saying is that the fear or the pain of having a world that seems, you know, without meaning or is unexplainable or unpredictable, that pain of that might actually be greater than the pain of taking on regrets
而在遗憾的情况下，我认为这可能是——以詹姆斯的例子来说，例如，不愿将这种巨大的损失视为一种无法预测、无法控制的事情。我认为，试图得出一个解释，即“这件事本可以被阻止，本可以被改变”，往往会带来很大的心理安慰，这样它看起来就没那么随机，也没那么毫无意义了。你知道，你刚才说的话让我很着迷，因为你本质上是在说，一个看似毫无意义、无法解释或不可预测的世界所带来的恐惧或痛苦——这种痛苦可能实际上大于因承担
for things that you actually maybe don't have responsibility for and experiencing personal anguish about it. That's a fascinating idea. Yeah, there's been research that says one of the ways that people can get a sense of control over their circumstances is by having these thoughts about what might have been. The dark side of that, along with personal regret, is there is also work where things like victim blaming can actually come out of these thoughts about what might have been. So if you think about a woman who attended a party and drank a drink that had been drugged and then was sexually assaulted.
你其实并不需要负责的事情而产生的遗憾，并为此经历个人痛苦。这是一个迷人的观点。是的，有研究表明，人们获得对环境控制感的一种方式就是通过思考“如果当时……会怎样”。这其中阴暗的一面是，除了个人的遗憾之外，还有一些研究表明，“谴责受害者”等现象实际上也源于这些“如果当时……会怎样”的想法。所以，如果你想到一个女人去参加派对，喝了一杯被下药的饮料，然后遭到了性侵。
Right? It's very easy to think about that one moment of she took this drink. And if she had been more careful, then this assault might not have happened to her. And that sort of gives us a sense of control, rather than the much more complicated thing to think about undoing of, well, how could we have prevented this person who gave her this drink and who committed this crime from doing it? So, yeah, these thoughts about what might have been help give us a causal structure to our world, but sometimes they're not necessarily the correct or the most useful ways of thinking about causality. the correct or the most useful ways of thinking about causality. Amy, let's listen to another story. This one comes from Tania Stock of Farmington, New Mexico.
对吧？人们很容易去想她喝了这杯饮料的那一个瞬间。如果她当时更小心一点，那么这次袭击可能就不会发生在她身上。这种想法给了我们一种掌控感，而不是去设想更复杂的事情，比如：我们该如何阻止那个给她下药并犯罪的人？所以，是的，这些关于“如果当初”的想法有助于为我们的世界建立一个因果结构，但有时它们不一定是正确或最有用的因果思考方式。艾米，让我们听听另一个故事。这个故事来自新墨西哥州法明顿的坦尼亚·斯托克。
I'm going to play the story in two parts because I think it reveals two different sides of regret. One of my biggest regret comes from something I did in the fifth grade, 20 or more years ago, I remember making fun of this little girl who was a bit overweight and me and another girl just teased her relentlessly. And I think about some of the things that I said to her and some of the ways that I treated her. And I just regret how cruel I was as a child. And now that I'm older and I work in a field where I see the effects of what bullying and
我要分两部分播放这个故事，因为我认为它揭示了遗憾的两个不同侧面。我最大的遗憾之一源于我五年级时做的一件事，那是20多岁或更久以前的事了。我记得当时取笑一个小女孩，她稍微有点胖，我和另一个女孩就无休止地捉弄她。我想起我对她说的一些话以及我对待她的某些方式。我只是为自己小时候的残忍感到后悔。现在我长大了，从事着一份能亲眼看到霸凌和
meaness does to children, I am so full of regret in that. And if I could ever find her again or talk to her again because I've moved to three or four different places at this point in my life and that have no idea where she is or if it even affected her, I regret the way that I treated her and I believe that I was so cruel. Amy, I want to talk about the role of guilt in regret. They seem closely tied these two emotions, but I don't think they're identical. Tom Bonsain from Arlington, Virginia regretted that he didn't get the lead in his school play, but there was no guilt involved. Tanya, on the other hand, feels terrible
刻薄对儿童造成什么影响的工作，对此我充满了遗憾。如果我还能再找到她或跟她说话的话——因为我在人生的这个阶段已经搬了三四次家了，根本不知道她在哪里，也不知道这是否真的对她造成了影响——我为自己对待她的方式感到后悔，并认为自己当时太残忍了。艾米，我想谈谈内疚在遗憾中所扮演的角色。这两种情绪似乎紧密相连，但我认为它们并不完全相同。来自弗吉尼亚州阿灵顿的汤姆·邦塞恩遗憾的是自己没有在学校话剧里当主角，但其中并不涉及内疚。而坦尼亚则对自己的所作所为
about what she did. When you hear Tanya's story, are you hearing guilt or are you hearing regret? So listening to Tanya's story, I would say I hear both guilt and regret, and both regret and guilt are emotions that are based on a form of comparison. So regret, I'm comparing what really happened to some imagined alternative. And some of the time, that's all we feel, right? I just imagined that something could have been better.
感到糟糕透顶。当你听到坦尼亚的故事时，你听到的是内疚还是遗憾？所以在听了坦尼亚的故事后，我想说我既听到了内疚，也听到了遗憾。遗憾和内疚都是基于某种形式的比较的情绪。就遗憾而言，我是在把现实发生的事情与某种想象中的替代方案进行比较。有时候，这就是我们的全部感受，对吧？我只是想象事情本可以更好。
Guilt involves an additional comparison to what has been called our personal standards rules and goals. So what are the things that we aspire to in our behavior? And when we make a comparison that says what we really did, fall short of those personal standards rules or goals for ourselves, then we're likely to feel guilt. I want you to listen to the second part of Tanya's story. She told us that she fully realized what she had done to this other little kid, only when events in her own life took a turn.
而内疚则包含了一种额外的比较，即与我们所谓的个人标准、规则和目标的比较。也就是说，我们在行为上追求的是什么？当我们进行比较，发现我们的实际做法未能达到这些个人标准、规则或目标时，我们就有可能感到内疚。我想请你听坦尼亚故事的第二部分。她告诉我们，只有在自己生活中的事件发生了转变时，她才真正意识到自己对那个小孩子做过什么。
I think karma came and got me because while I was a petite little kid, as I got older and do some injuries, I became quite overweight myself and heard the comments that were said about me or how I became invisible and like people didn't think that my feelings mattered. The heaviest I ever was was 300 and 30 pounds and I have worked hard and then have surgery and have lost quite a bit of weight. I'm just about 195 now, but I still see myself and still have the self-confidence of a 330 pound woman. And I know how it feels and I regret making anyone else
我觉得这是因果报应找上门了，因为虽然我小时候是个娇小的小不点，但随着年龄增长以及经历了一些伤病，我自己也变得相当胖，也听到了别人对我的议论，或者感受到了自己如何变得像隐形人一样，仿佛人们觉得我的感受根本不重要。我最重的时候达到了330磅，后来我努力工作，做了手术，减掉了相当多的体重。我现在大概195磅，但我看自己时依然带着330磅胖女人的自我怀疑和不自信。我深知那种感觉，我也后悔曾让任何人
ever feel that way. When you listen to Tanya's story, Amy, I'm wondering, do you hear sort of someone saying, I really don't like the way the world is treated me or do you hear someone saying, I really don't like the way the world is treated me, or do you hear someone saying, I realize the world is treated me really badly, and that's opened my eyes to the way that I might have treated other people in the past? It sounds like in Tanya's case, she's really developed a different understanding of the world,
有过那样的感受。艾米，当你听坦尼亚的故事时，我在想，你听到的是某人在说“我真的很不喜欢世界对待我的方式”，还是听到某人在说“我意识到世界待我真的很不好，这让我大开眼界，看到了我过去可能对待别人的方式”？听起来在坦尼亚的例子中，她确实对世界产生了不同的理解，
and use that to understand how her behavior may have affected other people, rather than necessarily being particularly focused on feeling that she's been treated badly. And I think that again, regret is based on this idea that we personally could have done something differently. And so in some ways, it's obviously a self-focused emotion. It's about what we should have done, but I think it can also be a fairly selfless emotion and be about how we relate to the people in the world around us.
并以此来理解她的行为是如何影响其他人的，而不是把重点放在觉得自己受到了不公平对待上。我认为，再次说明，遗憾是基于我们个人本可以做一些不同事情的想法。所以从某种意义上说，这显然是一种以自我为中心的情绪。它是关于我们本该做什么，但我也认为它同样可以是一种相当无私的情绪，关乎我们如何与周围世界的人建立联系。
What responsibility do we have towards our fellow humans? You know, psychologists have talked for a long time about something called the fundamental attribution era, which is how much do we believe actions of either ourselves or others are caused by things that are intrinsic to us, things that are part of our personalities, who we are, versus things that are shaped by the context, by the situation in which we find ourselves. When someone like Tanya looks back as an adult at her behavior as a child, do you think the fundamental attribution
我们对同胞负有什么责任呢？你知道，心理学家长期以来一直在讨论一个概念，叫做“基本归因谬误”，即我们有多大程度上相信自己或他人的行为是由内在因素引起的——也就是那些属于我们个性、造就我们是谁的因素，而不是由情境、也就是我们所处的环境所塑造的因素。当像坦尼亚这样的人作为成年人回首自己童年时的行为时，你认为基本归因
at her plays a role in some ways leading us to believe that we are responsible for things that maybe we were not responsible for, that maybe really the context was driving our actions and behavior way back when? Yeah, absolutely. Again, I think regret is based on this sense of personal responsibility. And certainly in Western cultures, there's very much this belief that individuals are responsible for our own destinies. And I think that can lead individuals to think more about how a given actor,
谬误在某种程度上是否在起作用，让我们相信自己要为那些也许并不需要由我们负责的事情承担责任，而实际上当时推动我们行动和行为的可能正是环境？是的，完全是这样。再次说明，我认为遗憾是基于这种个人责任感。当然，在西方文化中，很大程度上存在这样一种信念，即个人要为自己的命运负责。我认为这会促使个人更多地思考某个特定的行动者，
including themselves, or including another person, played a role, and a lot less attention to the whole context. So in Tonya's story, I believe she started by talking about how there was another little girl that she was friends with, who joined with her in the bullying. And I think it may be easy to ignore the degree to which she was experiencing peer pressure. Right? There was probably a social context in which this bullying occurred, which doesn't forgive
包括他们自己，或者包括另一个人，是如何在其中发挥作用的，而对整体情境的关注则要少得多。所以在坦尼亚的故事中，我相信她一开始提到过，她曾和一个小女孩是朋友，那个女孩和她一起参与了霸凌。我认为人们很容易忽视她在多大程度上受到了同辈压力的影响。对吧？当时肯定存在一个发生这种霸凌的社会环境，这虽然不能
it or excuse it, but it's not necessarily just about who Tanya is as a person to have done this, but rather really a much more complicated net of things that were influencing her as well as who she was at that time. I understand you got married about a year ago and you applied some of your own research on regret when it came to choosing a wedding dress. I did. So I actually wasn't applying my own research. I applied work by Shine Yanger on the phenomenon of choice overload, as well as work by Barry Schwartz and colleagues about
原谅或宽恕这种行为，但这不一定仅仅关乎坦尼亚作为一个人的本质，而是涉及一个更复杂的、影响了她以及她当时状态的网络。我听说你大约在一年前结婚了，在挑选婚纱时，你应用了自己关于遗憾的研究成果。是的。其实我应用的不是我自己的研究，我应用的是沈洋（Shine Yang）关于“选择过载”现象的研究，以及巴里·施瓦茨（Barry Schwartz）及其同事关于
the idea of maximizing versus satisfying strategies for decisions, maximizing being the idea that you want to pick the best of all possible alternatives and satisfying being the idea that you're going to pick something that meets all of your standards, but may or may not be the absolute best. So when I was wedding dress shopping, I went to a couple of stores, I tried on five or ten dresses at each one, and I found a dress that I absolutely loved and was in my price range. And I realized that what the research told me was I would never be happier than I was at that moment. That if I kept dress shopping, I was going to wind up feeling overwhelmed. You know, I could find a hundred different lace sheets with a V-neck in ivory.
决策中“最大化”与“满意化”策略的研究。“最大化”是指你想要从所有可能的选项中挑选出最好的那一个，而“满意化”是指你挑选的东西能够满足你的所有标准，但它可能不是绝对最好的。所以在我挑选婚纱时，我去了几家店，每家试了五到十件裙子，然后找到了一件我绝对喜爱的、且在我的预算范围内的婚纱。我意识到，研究所告诉我的结果是：我不会比此时此刻更快乐了。如果我继续逛街挑婚纱，我最终会感到不知所措。你知道的，我可以找到一百种不同的、带V领的象牙色蕾丝裙。
And I would wind up feeling confused about what are the differences between these, and that the very act of trying to get the absolute best would mean that I could never really be sure if I'd done it. Whereas if I adopted a satisfying strategy, I could be sure I'm in a dress that looks beautiful on me and is in my price range, and I should just buy it and be done.
而我最终会分不清这些裙子之间究竟有什么区别，仅仅是试图挑选出绝对最好的这一个行为，就意味着我永远无法真正确定自己是否做到了最好。然而，如果我采用满意化策略，我就可以确定我身上穿着一件看起来很漂亮、又在预算范围内的婚纱，我应该直接买下它然后大功告成。
And so that's how I chose my wedding dress. So for all your kids who think that research has no benefit in people's lives, that's a great example. Amy Samaville is a psychology professor at Miami University of Ohio. She runs the regret lab where she studies when and why people think about what might have been. Amy, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It's been a pleasure, thank you. After the break, we'll shift gears from looking back with remorse.
这就是我挑选婚纱的方式。所以，对于所有认为学术研究对人们的生活毫无益处的孩子们来说，这是一个极好的例子。艾米·萨默维尔是迈阿密大学俄亥俄分校的心理学教授。她主持“遗憾实验室”，研究人们何时以及为何会思考“如果当时……会怎样”。艾米，谢谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。我的荣幸，谢谢你。休息过后，我们将转换话题，不再回顾充满悔恨的过去。
It just really sticks with me. I shouldn't have been so afraid I should have been myself. To looking back with nostalgia. It turns out, reminiscing can have powerful psychological benefits. There is a big element of nostalgia that isn't about us retreating to the past. It's about us pulling the past forward to the present. I'm Shankar Vedantam and you're listening to Hidden Brain. This is NPR.
这真的深深印在我的脑海里。我不该那么害怕，我本该做我自己。转而回顾充满怀旧的过去。事实证明，回忆往事能带来强大的心理益处。怀旧中有一个很大的成分，并不是关于我们退回到过去。而是关于我们把过去拉向现在。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦，你收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。这里是美国国家公共电台（NPR）。
Welcome back to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Before the break, we examine one of the most common negative emotions in our lives. Regret, that feeling of disappointment about the job we should have taken, the friend we should have called, the person we should have married. Those what if moments that we think about over and over again. Now in this next segment we move from thinking about the times we wish we could change to how we think about the times we wish we could revisit. Depending on when you were born you might have a special reaction to one of these songs. I know I need it too so I'm really, really, I'm the champion my friend I wanna, I wanna, I wanna, I wanna, I wanna really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really popped up in your mind. Most likely, what you're experiencing is nostalgia. We take it for granted that nostalgia is an ordinary, harmless emotion.
欢迎回到《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。在休息之前，我们探讨了生活中最常见的一种负面情绪。遗憾——那种对本该接受的工作、本该拨打的电话、本该结婚的人感到的失望。那些我们一遍又一遍思考的“如果当时”的时刻。现在，在接下来的环节中，我们将从思考那些我们希望能够改变的时刻，转向思考那些我们希望能够重温的时刻。根据你出生的时间，你可能会对其中某首歌产生特殊的反应。我知道我也需要它，所以我真的，真的，我是冠军，我的朋友，我想，我想，我想……你脑海中可能浮现出了一首特定的歌。很有可能，你所体验到的是怀旧。我们理所当然地认为怀旧是一种普通、无害的情绪。
Nobody thinks you should go to a therapist for posting a photo from your childhood with the hashtag ThrowbackThursday, or if you have a weak spot for fruit loops or lucky charms. But that's a relatively new way of thinking. It started out very much as being considered a disease. And people even today, a lot of people will say, well, I'm not nostalgic because I think about the future. What exactly is nostalgia? I can nostalgia help us move forward in life
没有人会觉得你在社交媒体上发一张童年照片并加上“回溯星期四”（#ThrowbackThursday）的标签，或者对水果圈麦片（Fruit Loops）或幸运麦圈（Lucky Charms）情有独钟，就需要去看心理医生。但这是一种相对较新的思维方式。它最初被认为是一种疾病。甚至直到今天，许多人还会说：“哦，我不怀旧，因为我关注的是未来。”究竟什么是怀旧？怀旧能帮助我们在生活中继续前行吗
or does it simply leave us stuck in the past? Clay Rutledge is a psychology professor at Not Dakota State University. He's the author of Nostalgia, a psychological resource. Clay, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me. In your book you describe the origin of the word nostalgia, you say that in the 17th century, a medical student noticed that Swiss soldiers fighting in the planes of Europe were experiencing a set of emotions and physical symptoms. Other physicians ran with this idea and they thought nostalgia was a condition unique to Swiss soldiers.
还是只会让我们困在过去？克莱·鲁特利奇是北达科他州立大学的心理学教授。他是《怀旧：心理资源》一书的作者。克莱，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢邀请我来。你在书中描述了“怀旧”一词的起源，你说在17世纪，一名医学生注意到在欧洲平原上作战的瑞士士兵表现出一系列情绪和身体症状。其他医生顺着这个思路，认为怀旧是瑞士士兵独有的病症。
They believed that the endless clanging of cowbells in the Alps triggered some kind of trauma to the brain. Yeah, so there was a medical student named Johannes Hofer and be coined this term nostalgia, which he described as a cerebral disease of demonic cause that originated from continuous vibrations of animal spirits throughout the middle brain. That's basically the beginning of the term nostalgia. Of course, that doesn't mean that was the first time people ever experienced it or even noticed it, mean that was the first time people ever experienced that or even noticed it, but that was really the genesis of the study of nostalgia. So, we've obviously come a long way since those early conceptions of nostalgia, and you say that some of the people who have led the way were not researchers, but marketers?
他们相信阿尔卑斯山无休止的牛铃铛声对大脑造成了某种创伤。是的，当时有一位名叫约翰内斯·霍费尔（Johannes Hofer）的医学生，他创造了“怀旧”这个术语。他将其描述为一种由恶魔引起的脑部疾病，源于动物精神在中脑的持续振动。这基本上就是“怀旧”一词的起源。当然，这并不意味着那是人们第一次经历或甚至注意到这种情绪，
Yeah, I mean, that's one of the things that I think is really fascinating about this story, not just of what nostalgia is, but kind of the history of how people explored it is on the one hand in the early years of scholarship on the Stahlges. We just discussed there was this very disease-focused model and then fast forward to the 1980s, which of course were going from the late 1600s to the 1980s. And you see this more commercial driven or marketing or advertisement focused approach to nostalgia, which of course would paint a completely different picture of nostalgia. Because marketers don't think that people buy products that make them miserable. They think people buy products that they enjoy and that make them happy.
但这确实是怀旧研究的开端。所以，与早期对怀旧的理解相比，我们显然已经取得了长足的进步。你说，其中一些引领潮流的人不是研究人员，而是营销人员？是的，我的意思是，这是我认为这个故事非常迷人的地方之一，不仅在于什么是怀旧，还在于人们探索它的历史。一方面，在早期对怀旧的学术研究中，正如我们刚讨论过的，存在一种非常以疾病为中心的模式；而快进到20世纪80年代（当然时间跨度是从17世纪后期直接跳到了20世纪80年代），你会看到一种更具商业驱动、营销或广告导向的怀旧方法，这当然会描绘出一幅完全不同的怀旧图景。因为营销人员不认为人们会购买让他们痛苦的产品。他们认为人们购买的是他们喜欢并能让他们快乐的产品。
Parents love to tell about when they were kids. It's called the Falcons. I had a tonka truck. I'm an attached patch kid. I always loved dogs. And McDonald's hamburger, happy meal, would give you that nostalgic feeling. The summer that summers from here on will be compared to. We're memories will be forged into the sand and then hung on a wall for years to come. If you give people a list of products, things like movies or music or automobiles,
父母喜欢讲述他们还是孩子时的故事。这就是所谓的情怀。我曾有一辆Tonka玩具卡车。我是个Cabbage Patch娃娃迷。我一直很喜欢狗。而麦当劳的开心乐园餐，会带给你那种怀旧的感觉。从今往后的夏天都将与这个夏天相提并论。记忆将被镌刻在沙滩上，然后在墙上挂上多年。如果你给人们列出一份产品清单，比如电影、音乐或汽车，
people tend to have a preference for the products that were popular during their youth. And so people have this natural attraction to things from their past, was how this got started, and then, yeah, they started to look at, well, if that's true, then inducing that feeling, that connection to the past should increase favorability towards products. He once conducted an experiment where he tried to put volunteers into different kinds of moods.
人们往往会偏爱在他们年轻时流行的产品。因此，人们对过去的事物有一种天然的吸引力——这就是一切的起源，然后，是的，他们开始研究，如果这是真的，那么激发这种感觉、与过去的这种连接应该会增加人们对产品的喜爱度。他曾做过一个实验，试图让志愿者进入不同的情绪状态。
Some volunteers read about cute polar bears which were supposed to elevate their mood. Others read a neutral article about the solar system. Of course the sum of us is kind of cool but it's not the type of thing that gets most people super excited. A third group of volunteers read about the victims of a terrible tsunami. The idea was to put them in a negative mood. This last group of volunteers reported the highest levels of nostalgia. Now, it's important to note that, I mean, this doesn't mean that negative emotions are the only thing that triggered nostalgia. In fact, we know as the marketing researchers
一些志愿者阅读了关于可爱北极熊的文章，这些文章本意是提升他们的情绪。另一些人阅读了一篇关于太阳系的客观文章。当然太阳系挺酷的，但它不是那种能让大多数人格外兴奋的东西。第三组志愿者阅读了关于可怕海啸受害者的报道。这个想法是为了让他们陷入负面情绪。最后一组志愿者报告了最高水平的怀旧感。现在，需要指出的是，这并不意味着负面情绪是触发怀旧的唯一因素。事实上，正如营销研究人员所做的那样，我们知道你可以通过直接让人联想起过去的外界刺激来引发怀旧，比如熟悉的味道、景象或音乐。所以存在着一整套直接触发怀旧的感官和社会类型的刺激。但我们在情绪研究中发现非常迷人的是，似乎存在一类触发因素，它们与负面事件、生活经历或情绪有关，这些似乎会出于我们称之为补偿性原因或为了调节痛苦的心理原因来激发怀旧。换句话说，也就是心理防御。是的，没错。
have done that you can instigate nostalgia very directly with stimuli that remind people of the past, like familiar smells or sights or music. So there's this whole sensory and social type of stimuli that directly trigger nostalgia. But what we've found fascinating with this emotion research is that there seems to be a class of triggers that are about negative events or life experiences or emotions that appear to motivate nostalgia for more of what we call compensatory reason or psychological reasons that are about regulating distress. In other words, psychological defense. Yes, correct.
你就可以用那些让人想起过去的事物来非常直接地激发怀旧之情，比如熟悉的味道、景象或音乐。因此，有一整套感官和社会类型的刺激会直接引发怀旧。但我们在情感研究中发现的迷人之处在于，似乎存在一类触发因素，它们与负面事件、生活经历或情绪有关，这些因素似乎会出于我们所谓的补偿原因或心理原因来激发怀旧，这些原因与调节痛苦有关。换句话说，就是心理防御。是的，没错。
Now you and others have found that nostalgia is extremely common, very, very widespread, but I think a lot of people don't stop to think very carefully about the details of what constitutes a nostalgic memory or a nostalgic experience. And I want to try and do that in the next couple of minutes. And I want you to actually tell me about a picture that you keep on your desk that shows you standing with your wife and two kids in front of a mural in London. Describe the photo to me and then give me a play-by-play account of what images and memories the photograph produces in your mind. Are you aware of this band, Gorillas?
现在你和其他人发现，怀旧非常普遍，极其极其普遍，但我认为很多人并没有停下来仔细思考构成怀旧记忆或怀旧体验的细节是什么。我想在接下来的几分钟里尝试探讨一下。我想让你讲讲你桌上摆着的一张照片，上面是你和妻子及两个孩子站在伦敦一幅壁画前的合影。请向我描述这张照片，然后逐一告诉我这张照片在你的脑海中唤起了怎样的画面和记忆。你知道这个乐队“Gorillaz”吗？
So in London at least when we lived there, you know, on the South Bank, they had this really cool art that, so Gorillas, they have this graphic novel style art associated with their music, and so they had these murals that were just kind of neat. They look very animated and comic book-y. And so there's this picture of us, you know, standing there in the South Bank. Our daughter must have been around six and her son must have been around four or five. What this picture really means to me personally is here we were, it was, you know, we were poor. We didn't have really any material possessions at the time because we were in grad school, you know, we were poor, we didn't have really any material possessions at the time because we were in grad school. So it seemed like there's
所以在伦敦，至少在我们住在那儿的时候，你知道的，在南岸，有一些非常酷的艺术，Gorillaz乐队的音乐伴随着这种图形小说风格的艺术，所以他们有这些壁画，看起来非常别致。它们看起来非常生动，像漫画书一样。所以有一张我们的照片，你知道的，就站在南岸。我们的女儿当时大概六岁，儿子大概四 or 五岁。这张照片对我的个人意义在于，当时我们在那儿，你知道的，我们很穷。当时我们基本上没有任何物质财产，因为我们在读研究生，你知道的，我们很穷，当时我们基本上没有任何物质财产，因为我们在读研究生。所以感觉
nothing to lose. And so you have this picture that in many ways I think encapsulates that. And that's, I think what's so powerful and part about nostalgia is you have these snapshots of your life that capture these very, very rich and complex memories, these stories about yourself. And that one really to me is like, here we are, we've got these small kids, we moved to England, we don't know anyone there, and we're having this great adventure, and it's an adventure for my wife and I,
没有什么可失去的。所以你会有这样一张照片，在很多方面我认为它概括了那种状态。我认为这就是怀旧如此强大的一部分原因，你拥有生活的这些快照，它们捕捉到了非常非常丰富且复杂的记忆，关于你自己的故事。而那张照片对我来说真的就像是，我们在这里，我们有这些年幼的孩子，我们搬到了英国，我们在那里谁都不认识，我们正在经历这场伟大的冒险，这对我和我妻子来说是一场冒险，
but it's also an adventure for our kids and for the whole family. So there are a couple of things about this memory that stand out to me, and I think they're revealing about what your research and other research has shown about nostalgia. First of all, there is this bittersweet element to your memory of that day.
但对我们的孩子和整个家庭来说也是一场冒险。所以，关于这段记忆有几个让我印象深刻的地方，我认为它们揭示了你的研究和其他研究对怀旧的发现。首先，你的那段记忆中有一种苦乐参半的成分。
I mean, you're recalling the fact, for example, that you were poor, that you were dealing with small kids, that you didn't have any friends that you knew in London. So there are elements of the story that someone could hear and say, this is a story of sadness and loss. but it's also as you're telling it to me, this is also a story about a moment of family triumph, something that brought the family together. And I want you to talk about this idea that nostalgia has these two strains simultaneously, something that feels sad, but something that feels triumphant and happy as well.
我是说，举个例子，你正在回忆这样一个事实：当时你们很穷，要应付年幼的孩子，在伦敦没有认识的朋友。所以故事中有些元素，别人听了可能会说，这是一个关于悲伤和失落的故事。但正如你向我讲述的那样，这也是一个关于家庭胜利时刻的故事，一件让这个家庭凝聚在一起的事。我想请你谈谈这个观点：怀旧同时具有这两种情绪，一种是悲伤的感觉，但同时也是一种充满胜利和快乐的感觉。
One of the things that I found very interesting about this research in nostalgia is you have these very complex emotional experiences often involving great hardship and loss and struggle. But also, as you noted, there seems to be some kind of redemptive nature to them or triumphant nature to them or triumphant nature to them. In fact, some of the best nostalgic memories that we've collected were from when I was in England and we were doing this research as we had a sample of older adults. And these were older British adults who had, you know, were alive and were children, most of them during World War II, when Germany was bombing Great Britain. There are 279,000 children still in London. Many are bombed out of their homes, all looked
关于这项对怀旧的研究，我发现非常有趣的一点是，你们拥有这些非常复杂的精神体验，通常伴随着巨大的苦难、失落和挣扎。但正如你所指出的，它们似乎也具有某种救赎的性质或胜利的性质，或者说胜利的性质。事实上，我们收集到的一些最好的怀旧记忆来自于我在英国做这项研究的时候，当时我们有一个老年人样本。这些英国老人在二战期间，也就是德国轰炸英国时，都曾活着并作为儿童经历过那个时期。伦敦依然有27.9万名儿童。许多人的家被炸毁，这一切都看
hard, but they feel safe here. A good 100 feet below ground and their spirit and fortitude are simply grand. And a lot of these people had these nostalgic memories about serious family upheaval. Their dad being sent away to war, then being sent to the countryside because London was being bombed. Families being separated. And on the one hand, you could say these are really, really,
起来很艰难，但他们在这里感到安全。地下整整100英尺深，他们的精神和毅力简直伟大。这些人中有许多人对严重的家庭剧变有着怀旧的记忆。他们的父亲被送往前线打仗，然后因为伦敦遭轰炸而被送到乡下。家庭分崩离析。一方面，你可以说这些真的是，
bad, traumatic memories. But in nearly all of these memories that people, you know, wrote about for us, they had this, this experience of triumph, of, of, of gratefulness, of thankfulness for these times, because on the one hand, they were tough, but they also sort of stripped away all the nonsense of life and reminded them, you know, how precious it is and what's really important in terms of their family and their meaningful connections. So I feel like this often happens a lot in nostalgia as you really start to get at the
糟糕的创伤记忆。但在人们为我们写下的几乎所有这些记忆中，他们都有这样一种体验，一种胜利感、感激感，对这些岁月的感恩，因为一方面，它们很艰难，但它们也某种程度上剥去了生活中所有无意义的浮华，让他们想起，你知道的，生活是多么宝贵，以及在家庭和有意义的人际联系方面，真正重要的是什么。所以我觉得这在怀旧中经常发生，当你真正触及
core of what people find personally valuable and meaningful. And a lot of times that means suffering or loss or hardship. So I think what I'm hearing you say in some ways is that nostalgia might involve some amount of rewriting of the past. So, you know, we're seeing ourselves in some ways as the central protagonist of this movie. We're seeing, you know, the struggles and challenges we experience, but also the triumphs and the ways we overcame those those challenges. And in some ways these are, what the journalists and me would say that this might be misremembering the way things actually happened. But of course a psychologist would say, this is exactly what all human beings need to do.
人们发现具有个人价值和意义的核心时。很多时候这意味着痛苦、失落或艰难。所以我认为我从你那里听到的是，在某些方面，怀旧可能涉及对过去的某种程度的改写。所以，你知道的，在某种程度上，我们将自己视为这部电影的主角。我们看到了，你知道的，我们经历的挣扎和挑战，但也看到了胜利以及我们克服这些挑战的方式。在某种程度上，这是记者会说的话，这可能是对事情实际发生方式的错误记忆。但心理学家当然会说，这正是所有人类都需要做的事情。
We need to remember the kinds of things that we went through and we want to tell ourselves stories about the kind of people we are and how we became this way. And some rewriting of history, some recollection of the facts that suits our image of who we are today is what produces these nostalgic images. To me, I see it's almost like making a movie. You have all these memories that represent raw footage, right, of all the filming that you've done, and of course anyone who's seen him who's made a movie or watched a movie knows you don't go watch hundreds of hours of raw footage. That would be a horrible movie, right? Well, you have an editing process, a process where the director and editors and people
我们需要记住我们所经历过的事情，我们想要讲述关于我们是怎样的人以及我们是如何变成今天这样的故事。对历史的一些改写，对符合我们今天形象的事实的一些回忆，正是产生这些怀旧画面的原因。对我来说，我发现这几乎就像是在拍电影。你拥有所有代表素材的记忆，对吧，也就是你拍摄的所有胶片，当然，任何看过或制作过电影的人都知道，你不会去看几百个小时的原始素材。那将是一部糟糕的电影，对吧？好吧，你有一个剪辑的过程，在这个过程中，导演、剪辑师和参与电影的人，
involved with the film, well, you know, will sort of shape and edit the movie in a way that tells the story that that they want to tell or that features the most central themes in the, in a narrative and a meaningful way. And you know, we do that to some extent with our autobiographical memories as well. So it's not the case that we're necessarily completely fabricating memories so much as we're selecting and weaving these different memories into a meaningful self-narrative that helps us make some sense of our lives and our connection to others.
嗯，你知道的，会以某种方式塑造和剪辑这部电影，讲述他们想要讲述的故事，或者以一种有意义的方式突出叙事中最核心的主题。你知道的，我们在某种程度上对我们的自传式记忆也会这样做。所以这并不意味着我们一定在完全凭空捏造记忆，更多的是我们在选择并将这些不同的记忆编织成一个有意义的自我叙事，帮助我们理解我们的生活以及我们与他人的联系。
Now this doesn't mean it can't go wrong or that people don't have false memories, but I think a decent portion of this is healthy recollection that's not necessarily false, but does involve a certain level of massaging their footage, so to speak. When we come back, I'm going to talk to Clay about the effects of nostalgia. Is it a force for good or a force for bad?
但这并不意味着它不会出错或者人们不会有虚假记忆，但我认为其中相当大一部分是健康的追忆，不一定是虚假的，但确实涉及一定水平的对素材的“加工”，可以这么说。当我们回来时，我将与克莱谈谈怀旧的影响。它是一股向善的力量还是一股向恶的力量？
And I'm going to ask him about one of the most nostalgia-envoking presidential campaigns in recent history. We will make America great again. Stay with us. Welcome back to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Why are we so mesmerized by the touchstones of our youth? Just look at all the outpouring of glee around reboots of TV shows like the X-Files. I think those kids have been abducted. But who?
我还要问他关于近代史上最能唤起怀旧之情的总统竞选之一。我们将让美国再次伟大。请继续收听。欢迎回到《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦德坦。为什么我们如此着迷于青春的基石？只要看看《X档案》等电视剧重启时人们涌现出的狂喜之情就知道了。我想那些孩子被绑架了。但谁？
By what? Twin Peaks. This is a damn fine cup of coffee. And queer eye. Is Bray? Delay? And walk away. Today we're thinking about the power of nostalgia.
被什么？《双峰》。这是一杯该死的绝佳咖啡。还有《粉雄救兵》。是布雷？推迟？然后走开。今天我们在思考怀旧的力量。
And why the act of reminiscing can help us search for meaning and rewrite the stories of our lives. Believe it or not, tapping into treasured memories hasn't always been considered a great idea. When Johannes Hauffer came up with the word nostalgia more than 300 years ago, he thought of it as a brain disease essentially caused by demons. More recently, psychology professor Clearetta Lich has found
以及为什么回忆的行动可以帮助我们寻找意义并重写我们的人生故事。信不信由你，利用珍贵的记忆并不总是被认为是个好主意。300多年前，当约翰内斯·霍费尔提出“怀旧”这个词时，他认为这本质上是一种由恶魔引起的大脑疾病。最近，心理学教授克莱雷塔·利奇发现
nostalgia may actually be good for us. Yes, if you look within what we would refer to as normal populations, so these are research participants that don't have any particular vulnerability that might distinguish the way they recollect on the past, which you find as nostalgia seems to be generally a net positive experience that has a whole host of psychological benefits. I suppose it's possible for people to argue, you know, if you spend excessive amounts of time ruminating about the past and living in the past, this could also be bad for you. I mean,
怀旧实际上可能对我们有益。是的，如果你看看我们所说的正常人群，也就是那些没有任何特殊脆弱性的研究参与者，这种脆弱性可能会改变他们对过去的回忆方式，你会发现怀旧通常似乎是一种净积极的体验，具有大量的心理益处。我想人们可能会争辩说，你知道的，如果你花大量的时间沉思过去，活在过去，这对你来说也可能是件坏事。我是说，
isn't it possible that people who are spending huge amounts of time in the past, in some ways, I think your research and other people's research is suggesting, if distress causes people to become nostalgic, then people who are excessively nostalgic, could they not be people who are experiencing high levels of distress? Yes, I mean, in fact, that we find that that characteristics like loneliness, so loneliness, which we all experience from time to time, but it's also a trait, like some people tend to be more lonely than others, are associated with nostalgia
难道花大量时间停留在过去的人，从某种程度上来说，我认为你的研究和其他人的研究表明，如果痛苦导致人们变得怀旧，那么过度怀旧的人，难道不正是那些经历高水平痛苦的人吗？是的，我的意思是，事实上，我们发现像孤独这样的特征——孤独是我们偶尔都会经历的，但它也是一种特质，比如有些人往往比其他人更感到孤独——与怀旧有关，
as is neuroticism. So these negative emotional traits tend to be associated with nostalgia, but there's also a reason to suspect that these experiences in nostalgia are helping people restore some sense of psychological well-being while people are experiencing these emotions. Besides being an expert on nostalgia clay, you've spent a lot of time advocating for greater ideological diversity in the social sciences. You've made the case that more conservative voices need to be part of the conversation. I'd like to try and connect these two parts
神经质也是如此。因此，这些负面情感特质往往与怀旧有关，但也有理由怀疑，这些怀旧体验正在帮助人们在经历这些情绪时恢复某种心理健康感。克莱，除了是怀旧专家之外，你还花了大量时间倡导社会科学中更大的意识形态多样性。你提出需要有更多保守派的声音参与对话。我想试着将你生活的这两部分联系起来，
of your life, the researcher who studies nostalgia on the one hand and the person who's interested in conservative thought on the other hand, and I want to do it by talking about the 2016 presidential campaign of Donald Trump. Lots of presidential campaigns talk about the future. They talk about how changes coming about, hope for the future, but Donald Trump very specifically turned his attention toward the past. He invoked a sense of nostalgia among followers and he communicated the idea that America had seen brighter days and both he and his followers felt that they wanted to make America great again. I'm wondering whether the science of nostalgia has any insights into the appeal of Donald Trump and the success
一方面是研究怀旧的研究人员，另一方面是对保守派思想感兴趣的人，我想通过谈论唐纳德·特朗普2016年的总统竞选来做到这一点。许多总统竞选都在谈论未来。他们谈论即将到来的变革、对未来的希望，但唐纳德·特朗普非常具体地将注意力转向了过去。他在追随者中唤起了一种怀旧感，并传达了这样一种观点：美国曾有过更辉煌的日子，他和他的追随者都觉得他们想让美国再次伟大。我想知道怀旧科学是否能对唐纳德·特朗普的吸引力及其总统竞选的成功提供一些见解？
of his presidential campaign? Well, I think one thing that's important to distinguish is the difference between what we might call personal nostalgia and historical or some people call collectiveness. Now, a lot of the work that I've done, or nearly all the work I've done and pretty much everything we've talked about thus far, is about this idea of personal nostalgia, which is us revisiting memories from our own past, our own childhood or youth or whenever. These are our personal memories. That seems to be distinct from this more historical nostalgia, which you can imagine having nostalgic feelings for a period of time or for an idea
嗯，我认为区分我们可能称之为个人怀旧与历史怀旧（有些人称之为集体怀旧）之间的差异是很重要的一点。现在，我做的大量工作，或者说几乎我做过的大量工作以及我们到目前为止讨论的几乎所有内容，都是关于个人怀旧这个概念的，也就是我们重温自己过去的记忆，我们自己的童年或青年时期或其他什么。这些是我们的个人记忆。这似乎不同于这种更历史性的怀旧，你可以想象对一段时期或一个你从未有过直接接触的理念产生怀旧的情绪。
that you never actually had any direct contact with. So there are people, you know, to step outside of politics for just a second. There are people that have nostalgia for the 1920s. They just think everything about from the architecture to the fashion, that everything's great, and they never, you know, they never lived in that time.
所以有些人，你知道的，暂时跳出政治。有些人对20世纪20年代怀旧。他们只是觉得从建筑到时尚的一切都太棒了，而他们从来没有，你知道的，他们从未生活在那个时代。
So they can't really trace it to a personal or autobiographical experience. So I think that's important. What Trump seems to have done either by design or by just stumbling onto it was really latch on to this idea of historic nostalgia, that there's some kind of collective feeling of nostalgia that's beyond any individual experience that was about a time that perhaps was, at least for some, in their mind, imagine that was better. Now, of course, it doesn't mean that it was.
所以他们无法真正将其追溯到个人或自传式的体验。所以我认为这很重要。特朗普似乎无论是通过精心设计还是无意中撞上，都真正抓住了历史怀旧这个概念，即存在某种超越任何个人经历的集体怀旧感，它是关于一个也许至少对某些人来说在他们心中想象得更好的时代的。现在，当然，这并不意味着它真的更好。
What matters is that he sold the idea. I have to say, when I was young in high school and college, everybody used to say, we never lost a war. We never lost a war. You remember? You know what I hate? There's a guy totally disruptive, throwing punches. We're not allowed to punch back anymore.
重要的是他兜售了这个想法。我必须说，当我年轻在高中和大学时，每个人都说，我们从未输过一场战争。我们从未输过一场战争。你记得吗？你知道我讨厌什么吗？有一个家伙完全具有破坏性，到处挥拳。我们不再被允许还手了。
I love the old days. You know what they used to do to guys like that when they were in a place like this? They'd be carried out on a stretcher, folks. You know, I'd also add that it's not specific to Trump, though. That's, you know, clearly the most recent example from our culture, but there's actually, you know, people that have looked into Soviet era nostalgia, that there are people in Eastern Europe and Russia that have nostalgia for the Soviet Union, even if they are too young to really fully understand what was going on that time.
我喜欢旧时光。你知道他们以前对那种在这样的地方捣乱的家伙做什么吗？他们会被担架抬出去，伙计们。你知道，我还要补充一点，不过这并非特朗普所独有。那是，你知道的，我们文化中最近的例子，但实际上，你知道的，有人研究过苏联时期的怀旧，东欧和俄罗斯有人对苏联怀旧，即使他们太年轻，无法真正完全理解那个时代到底发生了什么。
So this idea of historical nostalgia is definitely its own kind of beast, and I don't feel like as far as the science of it, we have a full handle on it yet. So obviously it's much harder to study collective nostalgia and shared nostalgia, then it is to study individual nostalgia. You know, you can't bring countries into your lab and evaluate millions of people, but is it possible that at a collective level, nostalgia performs the same function that it does at an individual level? at a collective level, nostalgia performs the same function that it does at an individual level.
所以历史怀旧这个概念绝对是它自己的一种特殊存在，而且我觉得就科学而言，我们还没有完全掌握它。所以很显然，研究集体怀旧和共享怀旧要比研究个人怀旧难得多。你知道的，你不能把国家带进实验室去评估数百万人，但有没有可能在集体层面上，怀旧执行着与个人层面相同的功能？在集体层面上，怀旧执行着与个人层面相同的功能。
Yeah, I think that's a reasonable hypothesis. For example, people have noted that at the time of the following the economic recession in the United States, you saw this peak kind of interest in nostalgia products, whether it was reboots of movies or those types of cultural consumption products. Now, these aren't experiments, of course, and they're not even really scientific. They're in the sense that don't one try to systematically study this, but there was some acknowledgement that it seems like in times of collective upheaval, just like times of personal upheaval,
是的，我认为这是一个合理的假设。例如，人们注意到在美国经济衰退之后的一段时期里，你看到了对怀旧产品的这种激增的兴趣，不管是电影的重启还是这类文化消费品。现在，这些当然不是实验，甚至也不是真正的科学。从没有人试图系统地研究这一点意义上来说，但人们承认，似乎在集体动荡时期，就像个人动荡时期一样，
people seem to turn more into nostalgic feelings. So I think that's certainly a reasonable possibility. We talked earlier in our conversations about how recollections of our past might not necessarily be fabrications, but they are selective edits in some ways of our history. So, you have that photograph on your desk, if you're standing with your family in front of the London mural, and you remember the good parts of that history and your story, you don't necessarily remember that maybe that morning,
人们似乎更多地转向怀旧的情绪。所以我认为这绝对是一个合理的可能性。我们在之前的对话中谈到过，对过去的追忆不一定完全是捏造，但在某种程度上它们是我们历史的有选择性的编辑。所以，如果你和你的家人站在伦敦壁画前，你的桌上有那张照片，你记得那段历史中美好的部分和你的故事，你不一定记得也许那天早上，
maybe you weren't the best dad that you could have been. Maybe you were impatient or you were short tempered. I mean, you don't remember that part of it. You remember just the fact that you were facing a challenge with your family and you were on a big adventure. And I'm wondering, is the same thing possibly true at a collective level as well, which is, you know, we have these nostalgic memories, but is it possible there's an element of them that really is insidious, especially at a collective level as well, which is, you know, we have these nostalgic memories, but is it possible there's an element of them that really is insidious, especially at a cultural level? When you see the debate over Confederate memorials, for example, and the nostalgia that people feel over Confederate memorials, many people will say, this is tradition, and this is nostalgia, and there are equally many people on the other side who say,
也许你不是你能做到的最好的爸爸。也许你很不耐烦或者脾气急躁。我是说，你不记得那部分了。你只记得这样一个事实：你和你的家人正面临挑战，你们正在经历一场伟大的冒险。我在想，在集体层面上是否也可能存在同样的情况，也就是，你知道的，我们有这些怀旧的记忆，但有没有可能它们其中包含着一种确实具有隐蔽害处的成分，特别是尤其在文化层面上也是如此？例如，当你看到关于邦联纪念碑的争论，以及人们对邦联纪念碑感到的怀旧时，许多人会说，这是传统，这是怀旧，而另一边也有同样多的反对者说，
you're remembering a history that essentially has whitewashed, you know, the issue of slavery or the issue of race relationships from that memory and replaced it with this relatively grand and benign idea of tradition. How would you respond to that? Yeah, I think that's a fair point, even with example of personal nostalgia. Nostalgia can be a source of inspiration and a stabilizing force as well, but you shouldn't let it blind you or shouldn't be the only dimension through which you think about these issues, because you're absolutely right. It's part of our psychological immune system to, you know, more easily forget the negative
你们在记住一段本质上已经粉饰了奴隶制问题或种族关系问题的历史，并用一种相对宏大且温和的传统观念取而代之。你会如何回应？是的，我觉这是一个公正的观点，即使是以个人怀旧为例。怀旧也可以成为灵感的来源和稳定力量，但你不应该让它蒙蔽你的双眼，或者不应该成为你思考这些问题的唯一维度，因为你是完全正确的。这是我们心理免疫系统的一部分，你知道的，能更容易地忘记过去的消极特征，
features of the past, either through this revisionist process that you mentioned, or even through just natural recollection. I mean, a lot of negative memories fade from where and is faster than positive memories, and this seems to be adaptive for us personally, moving forward life, but it also biases us towards you know, not necessarily doing a good job of thinking about the complexities of the whole picture and thinking about other people's experiences, which may be giving the Confederate example vastly different than than our own. And so I do think that the nostalgia certainly has a number of positive benefits that we shouldn't let ourselves be intoxicated by Nostalgia because there are some
无论是通过你提到的这种修正主义过程，还是仅仅通过自然的追忆。我的意思是，很多消极记忆消退的速度比积极记忆快得多，这对于我们个人在生活中前行似乎具有适应意义，但它也让我们产生偏见，你知道的，可能无法很好地思考整体画面的复杂性，也无法思考其他人的经历，这可能会使邦联的例子与我们自己的经历大不相同。所以我确实认为怀旧有许多积极的好处，但我们不应该让自己对怀旧过于痴迷，因为其中存在着一些与之相关的真实危险。
real dangers associated with that. Klee and I wrapped up our conversation by talking about what he said was the most surprising finding about nostalgia. Nostalgia seems to actually orient people towards the future. And so part of what seems to be going on is you experience some kind of distress which kind of makes you shrink a little bit from pursuing goals and from the future. Like it does kick you into more of this defensive mode. And then you bring to mind these nostalgic experiences that they don't only make you feel good, we now have evidence that they actually make you feel optimistic and hopeful about
克莱和我通过谈论他所说的关于怀旧最令人惊讶的发现来结束了我们的对话。怀旧似乎实际上将人们引向未来。因此，其中发生的一部分事情似乎是，你经历某种痛苦，这会让你在追求目标和面向未来时稍微退缩。就像它确实会把你推入更多这样的防御模式一样。然后你脑海中浮现出这些怀旧的体验，它们不仅让你感觉良好，我们现在有证据表明它们实际上让你对
the future. And so that in turn seems to mobilize people, particularly in the social domain. And now we have a number of studies that show this both in terms of people reporting that they're more optimistic about the future, more inspired, but also behaviorally too in terms of people actually going out and wanting to interact with and meet people after they've engaged in nostalgia. So at one level actually this is surprising, but as you're talking just now, I realize this also makes perfect sense. I mean, people are nostalgic in every culture, and as far as we can tell, have always, you know, all historical reports suggest that nostalgia is very widespread. And when you see something that's as widespread as nostalgia seems to be, it's reasonable to draw
未来感到乐观和充满希望。这反过来似乎能动员人们，特别是在社交领域。现在我们有许多研究表明了这一点，无论是人们报告说他们对未来更加乐观、受到更多启发，还是在行为上，人们在参与怀旧之后实际上走出去并想要与人交往和见面。所以在某种水平上，这其实很令人惊讶，但正如你刚才所说，我意识到这也完全说得通。我的意思是，每个人在每种文化中都会怀旧，据我们所知，一直以来，你知道的，所有历史记载都表明怀旧非常普遍。当你看到像怀旧这样普遍的现象时，得出一个结论是合理的：它在发挥某种适应性功能，不仅帮助人们感觉更好，而且能让人实际表现得更好。
the conclusion this is performing some kind of adaptive function and not just helping people feel better, but in actually being able to function better. Nostalgia has had this historically had the stigma, as we talked about, it started out very much as being considered a disease. And people even today, a lot of people will say, well, I'm not nostalgic because I think about the future. I'm not the type of person that likes to fixate or get stuck in the past.
正如我们所讨论的，怀旧历史上一直带有这种耻辱感，它一开始很大程度上被认为是一种疾病。甚至直到今天，许多人还会说，“我并不怀旧，因为我关注未来。我不是那种喜欢固步自封或深陷过去的人。”
And I think what they're missing when they say that is, there is a big element of nostalgia that isn't about us retreating to the past. It's about us pulling the past forward to the present and using it to mobilize us, to energize us, to take on new challenges and opportunities. Claire Racklidge is a psychology professor at Not Dakota State University. He's the author of Nostalgia, a psychological resource. Clay, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Breasts.
我认为他们在这么说时所忽视的是，怀旧中有一个巨大的元素，它不是关于我们退缩到过去。而是关于我们把过去拉向现在，并用它来动员我们、激励我们，去迎接新的挑战和机遇。克莱·拉克利奇是北达科他州立大学的心理学教授。他是《怀旧：一种心理资源》一书的作者。克莱，谢谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。
Thank you for having me. This episode was produced by Raina Cohen and Laura Quarral, and edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Parts Shah, Thomas Liu and other Thieb Van Le Moody. I'm Sean Cravee Danton. See you next week. The X-Files has now considered our youth. The X-Files is like recent. When was the X-Files? Was it the 90s? Oh my god. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢邀请我。本集由雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）和劳拉·夸拉尔（Laura Quarral）制作，塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）编辑。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、帕茨·沙阿（Parts Shah）、托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）以及其他人员。我是尚卡尔·维达坦。下周见。《X档案》现在被认为是我们的青春。《X档案》就像是近期的事情。是什么时候的《X档案》？是90年代吗？哦，天哪。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。